darf man kinder für eine politshow
ausnutzen so geschehen ist das am
dienstagabend um 22 uhr 30 in der
prosieben show late night berlin oder
jetzt und klaas heufer-umlauf zu gast
ist kanzlerkandidat armin laschet der
sich den fragen von kindern stellen soll
doch normale kinder fragen sind das
nicht ist zum beispiel hier als es um
den ehemaligen verfassungsschutz chef
hans gerd maßen geht einer der
umstrittensten cdu mitglieder der zeit
du bist doch der chef der cdu
ist mars nazi nein ich bin immer einer
der gegen nazis gekämpft hat ja auch
nicht will dass die irgendwas zu sagen
haben mit denen reden wir nicht mit
denen man gar nicht gucken dass die
wieder wegkommen aus dem parlament
es hans georg massen 1 rechte
kennt zudem ja
warum ist das ein recht
wenn du mich fragst hans georg maas und
ein richtungstor wissen wir ernste
ausmaße an so etwas schlimmes gemacht
hat
dass wir teil nicht alles ich habe
andere meinung als er aber in der partei
gibt es heute schon solche leute und die
die da in thüringen wurden haben gesagt
wir wollen
ich sag doch gerade er ist in thüringen
das ist auch ein land in deutschland
aufgestellt und die leute die da sagen
wer soll eigentlich unseren kreis
vertreten die haben gesagt er soll das
machen da kann ich manchmal wenn er
etwas falsches sagt da widerspreche ich
ihm auch aber wenn da jemand sagt das
ist ein nazi das ist unfair das ist er
nicht und nazis dürfen nicht in der
partei seien
ja eigentlich
ist es wird sicher weiß es natürlich
nicht witzig zwei aspekte dabei zum
einen stellen natürlich kinder fragen
die kinder normalerweise nicht stellen
würden
zum anderen armin laschet auch ein
bisschen genervt müsste ein bisschen
lockerer vielleicht auch in ungarn sein
ich sag doch gerade
die beiden aspekte sind die die arme
fallen dabei
ich würde sagen amila sheen hätte das
set verlassen müssen als er gemerkt hat
dass die fragen an die kinder ja über
einen knopf im ohr kam erst danach auch
von vielen medien journalisten abbricht
oder auf twitter die kinder haben die
fragen wie er knopf im ohr bekommen und
laschet soll wohl genervt gewesen sein
weil erster das kind wohl zweimal nah
sie gesagt er ist die frage an richtig
raus kam mit dem nazi und dass man dann
so ein bisschen genervt ist vielleicht
auch mit blick darauf was sie mit den
kindern passiert dass sie
instrumentalisiert werden verstehe ich
ich hätte es ein stärker empfunden zu
sagen hier mache ich nicht mit tut mir
leid wenn kinder instrumentalisiert das
wäre für mich ein starker politiker
gewesen ich verstehe nicht wie die da
alle sitzen konnten und diese ist merkt
man nach der ersten frage das ist
orchestriert ist und ich glaube armin
laschet hat den fehler gemacht er hat es
dem kind ja eigentlich vorgeworfen wenn
du mir diese frage stellt dann musst du
wissen dass ein rechter ist das ist
natürlich komplett falsch zu sagen
müssen wir merken jetzt gerade dass die
frage nicht von dir kommt und ich möchte
deine fragen was interessiert dich denn
ich glaube es hätte offenlegen müssen
weil das ist das was im moment fehlt
vertrauen in die politik und wenn
natürlich verbinden politiker noch bei
so einem kinderspiel mitmachen wo kinder
ausgenutzt werden für die agenda und ja
hier muss man die frage aufwerfen ist es
die agenda von klaas heufer-umlauf ich
meine dass klaas heufer-umlauf keinen
cdu wähler ist es weiß man seine show
kommt schon sehr stark rüber als hätte
er die kinder doch niemanden raus müssen
die abend kinder jetzt die fragen
stellen die sich erwachsene offen weil
ich fragen trauen also und dafür
schicken wir dann die kinder vor ort
damit sie mit knopf im ohr dann die
fragen stellen ich bin mir relativ
sicher dass die beiden pauline und romeo
heißen vielleicht er vorher noch gar
nicht wussten wir maßen überhaupt ist
also welches kind beschäftigt sich schon
damit also wie du sagst warum nicht
authentische kinder fragen warum nicht
die echten kinder fragen warum nicht die
themen die kinder wirklich interessieren
das hier war ja keine sendung für kinder
patricia das war eine sendung für eine
politische agenda und kinder wurden
eingesetzt um die um die durchzuziehen
und das ist natürlich schon mal verlogen
und es ist aber klaas heufer-umlauf hat
ja auch sehr viel kritik dafür bekomme
in sozialen medien und ich bin mir ganz
sicher dass er das nicht noch mal so
machen wird in vier jahren ich glaube
die kritik ist angekommen ist das
ziemlich daneben war
[Musik]